2022 has been a tough year but it's been
especially tough for one group of
americans the middle class has gotten
absolutely squeezed they've lost more
than the people who make more than them
they've saved less than the people who
make less than them and they're being
hit the hardest by inflation
how did this happen
i'm going to walk you through the
financial data that show how the middle
class is feeling the squeeze
first just who makes up the middle class
the federal reserve classifies american
households into six income categories
and the middle class is made up of the
groups in the middle of u.s income
distribution that's households that earn
about forty eight thousand dollars to
about one hundred twenty seven thousand
dollars a year data show this group is
getting hit hardest by just about
everything new research from bank of
america found that middle-class
americans were seeing prices rise by 9.4
in may from a year before versus an 8.6
inflation rate for all americans
that's the highest rate for all income
groups and it's largely because folks in
the middle class spend a larger share of
their income on driving and auto
expenses and those costs have
skyrocketed the middle class has lost
the biggest share of its assets in the
stock market the loss has been larger
than even the top one percent of
households which own more than half of
all equity and mutual fund shares
according to federal reserve data so
even though middle-class households own
less stocks they lost a bigger
percentage of what they do have in the
first quarter downturn fed data also
showed that the middle class is taking
on more debt households earning between
75 and 127 000
now hold the most consumer credit debt
of all groups
outpacing even households that earn
twice as much or more and data from
moody's investor service shows those
upper middle income americans have less
savings than every group except the
lowest income americans and they reduced
their savings in the fourth quarter of
2021 and the first quarter of 2022 by
more than any other group
so why did this happen economists at
moody's say it's largely result of these
middle-class households being excluded
from stimulus checks and income-based
tax credits
many also lost their jobs during the
pandemic and received unemployment
benefits that were less than their
previous wages
with lockdowns ending and prices rising
they've eaten into their savings and
taken on debt to keep up with purchases
wages for the middle class are
increasing but well below the rate of
inflation meaning these households are
losing money every month
only the lowest income households are
seeing wage gains that are above
inflation according to calculations by
economist aaron dube
the bottom line is the middle class got
squeezed to start the year and with
inflation still hot and markets
continuing to struggle
there's no sign this squeeze will be
short
we heard az tell us on nasa's classic
album illmatic that he was visualizing
the realism of life in actuality forget
who's the baddest a person's status
depends on salary and my mentality is
money orientated i'm destined to live
the dream for all my peeps who never
made it
that's all for now see you next time